welcome into this video round 1 coverage
of town memorial 2013 and it has been
known rather spectacular round with a
couple of wins a couple of decisive
games on the only issue is some with
this video that I'm starting this
recording now already a past midnight
German time and I only just returned
from some event in my chess club so I
couldn't really prepare anything and the
choice was to simply do this recording
tomorrow with some thorough preparation
but this means somehow it is really late
or do am a video I'm basically without
any prep just go through the moves and
make it up as I go along the moose
didn't have anything prepared I only
roughly know how the games went so
please forgive me if this is a bit bumpy
compared to some other presentations
where I have some basic story laid out
for a game awesome idea how it turned
out at the end let's start with them
with the less exciting games I only went
through them briefly on my mobile phone
on the way back from the club but you
cannot really call that analysis let's
start with them and Drake in with white
against moral davitch and okay Mauro is
a well-known player and raking maybe not
so much is the Russian champion from I
think last year this last year or the
year before um yeah anyway he's a very
strong GM above 2700 pretty pretty young
player so it is I think early 20s like
20 years old or 21 or something about is
about Magnus Carlsen's age
I think and let's see what happens so
it's a dragon if I remember correctly
yes we get get the dragon and this is
quite curious under a can I think place
any first move I'm ad for you foresee
for a place the more but I don't think
that more Rosa which is really am a
dragon player it surprised i didn't i
didn't check it maybe he's added this
recently to his repertoire in any case
we get the main line with the long
castles here i'll move nine of course
white has the choice between Bishop c4
this is the classic Yugoslav at egg and
then then going long h4 h5 attack on all
long castles the difference is sometimes
with Bishop c4 you need to play Bishop
c4 boo should be three you waste not
waist but let's say invest two moves and
it's not so clear that this is actually
necessary and therefore in all cases is
interesting and this is what Dragan
played the main argument the classic
main argument follow for Bishop c4
always was that you want to use the
bishop on c4 do to increase control of
d5 as long castles he allows d5 and this
is what moral played it yeah it looks a
bit strange maybe to play first d6 and
95 but d5 is the classic advanced that
very often equalizes the game for black
here white as many options you can take
on d5 and on c6 to get to win a pawn but
it's not them not so promising I think
King do you wanna sir tricky little move
the idea so if black takes on d forge
we're also which did white place the
movie 5 this looks a quite funny but
it's it's interesting
one thing I need to show King be one the
ideas also after takes the do i do ins
instantly with no check c6 because Queen
d2 isn't a check anymore so right can
insert the center median movement win
this is a point of qb1 ok 94 w 5 this is
really funny if he ignores this and the
text they have 69 yeah blacker actually
saves the d4 Knight and retreats there
five now why it took on f6 and black
took with the porn this is a very
weird-looking opening line but i think
it's um it's well known actually it has
been played before i think also in a
game of carlin's with black against
short a couple of years ago the idea is
that black tries to get this important
bishop and white took now i think
there's even this idea Bishop to c5
attacking the rook and then black can
sacrifice the exchange quite quite funny
hoping to exploit the very weakened dark
squares but okay just just took the five
and after takes we had a position where
why does yeah brought up he's the
league's got an extra porn oh it doesn't
have sorry i cannot count ah why it's
got six points blacks got six points as
well it looks like an extra porn like
this free against two but then I didn't
know I'm sorry just a hallucination yeah
then I think black shouldn't have any
problems he at all he's got two bishops
and doesn't this isn't a better Bishop
g7 let's see what happens i think why to
try to trade down one very quickly yeah
93 attacking the queen
so that this exchange happened and now
look you 12 to a techie 6 yeah why does
some slightly more actor here with this
night only six but then probably it
won't lead to anything substantial likes
giving up this pawn to set up this the
strong pin and to simplify yeah yeah
this is some quite Josh I would say over
too soon the g6 point it's irvin can
easily get lost let's see what happens
okay okay you're taking with the pawn
just gives away the this is Pawn need to
take what's wrong and now what even got
the H tampon but the drawing margin and
then rook endgames us a notoriously high
and here black has got a good King ready
to to join the battle it's much better
King than the white one here won't be
one blacks quadruped e2 that's a
possibility yeah the only thing in favor
of why this is extra porn but okay it's
um it's rather drawers yeah likes
playing in an active manner shouldn't
stay passive at all
that tries to exchange more pawns this
is a weird okay white could have taken
here but objects before yeah I still
think this is probably a draw like it's
very active the game this happened yeah
okay this is this is really a drop let
ebay played a couple mono known now
there was the drawing grid white only
has the some rather symbolic extra
podium it's so not much happening yeah
it seems like a rather uneventful draw
this night XD five idea of getting into
into an endgame probably doesn't eat too
much maybe white had some way to to
improve and actually keep a little bit
of something but it's not a parent okay
let's go to gelfand coyoacán and both
players actually have a rather narrow
opening repertoire galfond has played
the catalan all his life on an office
varying but he's played this opening for
a very long time even before it became
so popular and kayaking always plays
this t5 line so exactly this position
was something you could expect Quincy to
a six and we get the classical main line
of them of the Catalan now be should be
to which is the most popular move
nowadays and the only one which really
AM has some little bit of vibe to it
other lines are solid and not completely
yeah they are not completely harmless
but Blake knows what he's doing on that
level it's very dry we should be too is
the way to go if you play for false
image 56 yeah rookie won it tends to
play in form and black stops that with
the bishop and now just retreats it's a
weird maneuver but this term is actually
quite common in then the castle on there
are some other lines where this is
happening as well the queen is misplaced
on c1 and so now he for is not possible
anymore and in this position probably
the best move is Quincy to but okay this
is just the repetition he actually
played that but now went with a three to
avoid the draw of course Gavin is not
interested in drawing at 15 boosie once
a fight with white why does some
pressures yeah a three and one of whites
ideas is to play Bishop f5 and to play B
form to stop any expansion on the
queenside and make sure that this c7
palm stays weakness we see that now but
before
what krk manages to play me five and
this is of course very important to open
up the position and get rid of any cramp
in your position you only need to
exchange the lightscribe bishops now and
managed to place you 5 and black has no
problems at all takes temple and now the
preparation is 45 and also okay blacks
got some peace activity than those
pieces in the center are not not bad at
all yeah I tending to play nazi for this
is something that white must stop I
think he took idiom okay not at the
moment but very soon now okay you don't
need to take it at the mode C files oops
nan up this one this is protected not c4
not possible I black cannot move the
seaborne but otherwise is completely
fine I took now now white join this
crooked arrows white wants to go to d5
you manage you probably have some
advantage yeah this is a problem so
after Bishop g7 why didn't he play 93
instantly oh there's this one down the
pin yeah this is what black needs to get
cannot allow 95 this would be terrible I
mean the game he also didn't manage
Bishop h6 that this is very important
check hmm isn't this better for white I
mean it's no a question at all that
white with this extra porn on the King
side is better in some way but the
question is how much black of course has
got some cool to play and okay it's a
real good game they are very often the
draw hmm interesting
yeah the thing is what black yarn needs
to to accomplish is to just get those
two pawns oops these two pawns for the
three points so just the queenside
should be traded and then there's still
this four against three and game that
should be relatively comfortable draw
now but this is what what you should go
fall let's see what what happened yeah
black is just going for the active rook
oh no not drawn even so maybe there
really wasn't wasn't anything yeah
what's what should why do I play whoopty
for we saw that join the game Lucas e2
and what to do now what this pawn is
hanging others also he's gonna lose
maybe if I if you can try that
yeah this is probably a draw even this
is as possible you're in the porn down
yeah it should be you should be a draw
yeah so they agreed also to this draw
but at first you might think okay isn't
this something the spawn for white but
black is too active he's got all those
ideas to attack whites formation as well
okay so let's go to the next game so
turn to hunt against koala we have a
ruler PES Anna does some variable steady
protection practitioner of the way very
very rarely i cannot really remember
something else plays like something like
the Italian game Bishop c4 or the scotch
and this is in fact rather uncommon lots
of top players that mean who mainly play
the the way and have some sort of sight
line available like the Scotch but this
she always plays the Spanish I think
okay we have from a marshal Tribeca
wanna so this invites the marshal will
see three to d5 so our c3d five um which
is them still in an excellent
theoretical shape it seems so 10 it goes
for age 31 of the entire marshal lines
there should be 73 and he'll like it's
got a very interesting move on which
really was a revolutionary back when it
was first played a couple of years ago
and this is d 5 it looks crazy at first
because it takes d5 95 yeah what about
the five pole this isn't a marshal but
the funny thing is that after nine takes
five
Mac has got the funny move 94 and it
seems that this gambit really gives
enough compensation black will get the
important ruia bishop and the
compensation for the pawn he's got the
bishop pair nicely positioned central
pieces and some pressure possible line
for example is something like this where
the night on before also exerts some
pressure on the queenside this is in
fact rather tricky to play for white why
does not worse I'm not saying that but
it's definite compensation in the game
and I didn't take he just played 90 to
continue developing now f6 to support
the pawn it looks a bit shaky playing
them like f6 but white doesn't really
have fun any way to exploit it just see
3 and King educate of course you cannot
stay in this diagonal all the time King
a jade and Bishop c2 yeah I'm not sure
if the Sun has been seen before and as
mentioned didn't have the time to do any
proper preparation but generally
speaking on thing gets it would be quite
remarkable if white um would be able to
get anything substantial here black is
got healthy developed pieces pieces good
knight on d5 this idea and yeah like
doesn't really have anything um yeah
please placed on a bed square I mean it
looks like a very nicely centralized
position okay Bishop c2 anyway
7-night be 305 yeah this is very direct
and a for other sis kisses curious okay
night to before yeah i think the
sacrifice a pawn right one can take care
where did that so black sacrifice the
porn and what did you get in return yeah
two bishops and really nice bishop here
after this Knight b6 there's really the
threat to capture on f3 guess this is
yeah this is easily covered but okay
it's clear that while white has an extra
porn it also has rather clumsily place
pieces and black Scott the exhibition
p.m. Oh g5g for I mean this is a move it
opens up everything very quickly yeah
night h2 is not a happy move but yeah
maybe it was necessary
hmm black just takes it is Evan saying
I'm sorry at c7 okay Bishop before but
this already looks a tad shaky for white
suddenly need to play precisely here to
not get into any serious trouble like
it's gotten very active position yeah
now you can take on the form very ugly
nitra phone what about Queen sees and
hears this completely unplayable getting
this porous is really important because
this is the last pawn which is
potentially a passport if the beep on
gets lost the seaport gasp ass porn and
this position here there's only those
free porns left so this might help to UM
to simplify this one
something like this yeah blacks got
enormous pressure not sure though if it
is really good enough for for an edge
interesting enough the computer wants to
play rupee 7 that's quite interesting
attacking f6 was checking this is really
difficult to cover and also at the same
time covering be 798 so probably you
need to give this may know maybe this
one yeah I have no idea what's going on
probably at some if white gets the spawn
here on g5 for the b2 point it's
probably very dry we are interesting but
white is really already hanging a bit
here bye-bye a threat king of night to
f1 well then what so was this move three
hmm yeah this looks excellent for black
why do you go now the game he exchanged
c2 yeah of course black is better with
the bishops
yeah black is some uncomfortable but i'm
not sure that white really should lose
it's got some ideas for for possible
fortresses yeah nice very it is very
very unpleasant though two bishops are
simply excellent so spin going terrible
to play okay so maybe you missed that
one even now this is this is terrible
now the bishops are simply very very
strong here okay of course you can you
can just do that this is not not
playable at all and King takes which is
oops which was played I think you get
this and flex intending to win many
pawns yeah this is busted now yeah still
continued for couple of moves yeah yeah
here the work champion resigned yeah and
that is really in a shaky shaky an ode
to call it it's a lot in good shape
really generally it's a once in a while
there's a good game but he simply losses
so many games that also with Wyatt he
also lost with wide against kawada
earlier the CN some some way and tell us
a one nice game against a piranha but he
lost I think at least two games and I
don't know somehow he he doesn't really
um
to fill those positions right at the
moment I don't know I hope he gets in
good shape for the World Championship
match otherwise this will be a disaster
to be honest I actually believe that
this match could be really really tight
and and difficult to fear from four
cards but V she is not in top shape it
will be a very one-sided okay um two
games left let's go to Garrett let's
actually go two cards we had a big game
console against Kramnik world number one
against um is it too i'm not sure i
think our only at this number two it's
got a couple of more points the chronic
but I really a big gameand much prestige
here so let's see what Carson has
prepared for this game the Trump offski
quite quite funny it's a 3d amazing he
really plays some it is really it's a
whole repertoire consists of those sight
lines that are prepared for one game and
he does it again and again um okay it's
not a bad opening but it's not the kind
of opening you would expect from the
very likely future world champion okay d
5 by chronic very solid choice against
the Trump and now III waiting a moose um
what quite often also takes him but
after he takes some black ass and quite
solid shape GTX f is also playable buddy
Texas is simpler yeah III he waits a
moment and only after c5 he took on f6
retakes and takes on c5 so what happened
here like spawn structures slightly
compromised but of course why it has
given up the two bishops e6 93 and then
I did check this briefly before
this is actually only been played one
time before in the whole of the five and
a half million games and my my database
so by mu six the world number one and
world number three player play a game of
chess without any computer aided
preparation norm or big work at home
behind all the move um in fact i think
it's an excellently played game up to
the ending up to the end game white
returns upon yeah and yeah this is
actually interesting moment black also
could have taken on c6 but he decided to
play Knight b6 the problem is if white
takes on v7 lexa development is really
coming to life even this year getting
rid of castling it's not really helping
this is already an excellent position
for black with this great bishop so just
92 c 3 we have got those now this
structure on black stop the bishops but
white is some slightly healthier phone
wise but the double pawns are not an
issue for black i would assess this as
round equal i think actually that it
stayed equal for very long time an
interesting moment yep like doesn't mind
to this kind of structure okay he
actually can take on s III but even this
i mean it's not a structure that black
is some so worried about because with
the two bishops you have a good
attacking Target to target to take on on
c3 so rooks you want covering c3 and i
guess it's all fairly logical like as
activating pieces getting
this traded and we reach interesting
position 95 takes 56 and now we get an
interesting a transposition white is
playing a 5 group d 4 take stakes and
now this this night is strapped it
doesn't have a natural square so wide
sacrifice is only six and we get this
position where it's clear that white is
very slightly probably better simply
because of a healthy porn structure
compared to three single islands but
still it's a rock end game I think it's
still very Jewish we can put a couple of
more moves on the board the c12 what
happened to him yeah why does pressing a
bit he's got more pawns to attack
yeah yeah Dwight actually has one upon
but black now Scott counter play with
the depot yeah yeah maybe around TM
there are ways to to improve that maybe
bouquet one something like this
yeah wyd will play with the six and
exert some pressure on the porn mmm yeah
it's not easy I'm not sure if white
should win this I think white stone has
got some some chances to win the black
also can fight for the straw or cromley
played us I'm not sure really traded
those two pawns and no yeah yeah this is
this is the main thing here at this game
here black and absolutely needs to keep
the books on the board someone would
like let's say look at you may be there
there are others probably but we'll get
to is the most logical what you need to
do is absolutely you cannot exchange
rooks what he did is rook f6 and this is
really am losing my force it's no way to
to hold the position of course what
kramnik was hoping for White has got the
light squared Bishop and this is a dark
square so the H porn always has this
problem of the wrong colored bishop so
basically what black needs to do is you
need to exchange the bishop on g6
against the pole on g2 and then put the
King in the corner and you simply draw
this but the issue is you simply cannot
manage to do that quite simple keeping
the pawns white gets the deep one and
this is simply not a draw not quite sure
what chromium overlooked them the
problem is oops one at some point you
will put like a desert swung or simply
get those kind of maneuvers in where you
get rid of the enemy bishop and after
that push the G point it's actually a
fairly simple technical term
yeah paving the way and now the Jeep
onus is moving yeah of course you you
cannot take now this is an instant drop
even with the six points it would be a
draw um in the corner so white just
pushes just now here he's very near now
the desired promotion squares the no way
for black to stop stop that you played
King a jade and now Bishop g8 trading
the bishops form one King opponent game
but black simply didn't have any
movement left if you play this for
example white plays Bishop f7 and after
that yeah you already promote to pure
Queen so I'm a tactical win at the end
for calls as it happens so often that
you wins the endgame probably around he
has a question where I Cromley could
have defended better to be honest it's
very difficult to make a proper
assessment of such a high level game
without having taken time to look at
various options check it with the
computer and make sure that you're not
talking complete nonsense maybe around
here there was some way to to better
defend this I'm not really sure that
black should lose the game it's a it's
difficult of course but it's not clear
that this should actually happen in this
in this end game here I think black
really should draw its active enough
with the rooks tool to draw that to get
into some endgame we're losing a porn
it's not fatal should be possible ok but
so got a game left in a camera against
Mammadyarov and
yeah I camera playing d4 and we get a
queen's gambit Rogozin the Rogozin
variation here with bishop before this
is some sort of hybrid between the
Queens gambit declined we're very often
the bishop is just going to e7 and the
NIMS oh it's some Queens gambit with
enemies of flavor in fact if you look at
maggiano's move order here after Knight
c3 Bishop before this is what he
probably would have played and after
nine f3 the other main move played in
this game you play this this Rogozin
line and then you have a very nice
opening repertoire consisting of those
Bishop before set up so it's quite a
good good idea if you look for some
opening advice okay now can we replace
queen a 4 here White has got many
options mostly playing Bishop g5 or
taking and then we should be five Queen
a4 is not bad at all but it's less I
think less threatening that it then its
first impression at least quite a while
ago where thought okay this night is
really misplaced and Queen a form with
the check is probably worth spending a
tempo on to misplace the night but in
fact it is on the case that blacks got
pretty good and healthy development we
see in the game I can warn our place III
which is some rather modest smooth i
would really prefer to to play Bishop g5
or maybe take and then play
g5 but ok this wasn't narcos plan he
played III and this was the idea player
rather simple model set up get your
pieces out but have a look at this Lex
now um yeah probably not threatening it
immediately but it introduces this idea
of playing a b5 so wyd really needs to
spend the move in the long run and he
does so quickly only later I thought
okay but should be six but I need to
explain why black drops back now those
two pieces are now nicely placed to
support a 65 and if you manage to play
65 without getting instantly wiped out
then then you are an excellent excellent
shape and in fact white has no one big
idea here like even can play me five
with the look post the Queen exchange
and now be should be too yeah somehow I
think around here maybe I'm some
improvement is needed for Nakamura he
very quickly gets into an uncomfortable
position and this really shouldn't be
the case I should happen with white he
had this energy 5 i'm not sure that this
was so brilliant
yeah let's have a look at this position
which is a very very harmonious one for
black everything's perfectly centralized
the rooks bishops everything's nice wide
also has got a rather ammonius nice
position but it is in comparison to do
black set up and it's slightly passive
here in fact black and hasn't has a
concrete threat this is taking on a
three and twenty five so what white
needs to react in some way I think the
best move now is probably h3 which after
this even allow us to play g3 because
the bishop capture after Bishop f4 is
not not clear at all but g3 is what
nakamura played and I think this move
was some probably close to were losing
for white meridia of plain IG form is an
excellent attacking player so he smelled
this rather quickly and what is the idea
yeah it is simply too okay a techie for
but also make pressure on f2 and in fact
the camera now played the move h3 after
which Mammadyarov probably didn't think
for too long and no not really is he 30
seconds he had this worked out before of
course but he just can't sacrifice this
piece now King takes and Bishop h3 and
no legs got two points he's attacking
third one is it is getting Knight g4 in
the mix and dumb if you want to have
some fun you can try to let the computer
defend the white side and it's a
complete disaster white is completely
really lost now
and the game simply doesn't take take so
much longer King g1 is one of the Radley
best moves 93 and now you see these two
great bishops have cornered this rock
and yeah this it will be taken Black
Stars got all the attack good
simplification taking on a three and
then Queen d6 to attack at the bishop
and to get this idea in that we see that
just a couple of moves later why does
some completely falling apart we'll see
six and now just the check and queen fo
now wide wide resigned one point is that
this is exceptionally awful yeah a
complete wipe out here of Nakamura but
somehow all this is opening really
didn't didn't really give white anything
here probably needs to pay this h3 move
d 395 does this already lost according
to the computer funny enough it's not
like some edge sure or anything but
really like a lost position um white can
can try it you to do this normal fashion
white can can try something like night
to deform but there's always this
pressure on f2 can sacrifice iam
tending to dig ya White's King isn't a
terrible crossfire many possible ways to
take the egg white so I cried a disaster
from the camera to lose with y to the
first game so we have three M decisive
games Carlton beating Kramnik in an
exceptionally important game for this
tournament now come we are losing with
white against Mammadyarov and are not
losing with white against kawana so Alan
term having a really bad start again in
one of those big tournaments okay so
this was the at the end still rather
long video or 45 minutes and i hope you
enjoyed it anyway despite my only very
very brief preparation the kind of let's
check on the mobile phone what kind of
opening they played but i hope it worked
out entertaining and in an entertaining
and still formative fashion thanks for
watching I'll be back tomorrow with
round two